hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for June 24 2009 teen what's going on
how are ya what's up how's everybody
doing are you having a nice week well
that's good that's good
Alby I'm in a [ __ ] melancholy mood I
really have some [ __ ] going on
you know she get older things happen to
people that you love and it [ __ ]
sucks
so with that we're gonna plow through
with that we're gonna plow through we're
gonna plow through we're gonna bring the
comedy through the pain getting on this
jokester train its Billy and he's got on
his clown makeup Jesus Christ I didn't
realize the [ __ ] [ __ ] I was gonna
stir up telling that funny story about
the club that didn't put me on and then
everybody started going like you know
that Club I gotta tell you they they do
some things that are not exactly things
that you might want to be doing to
people so now I'm kind of glad I didn't
go up there but anyway I've been I've
been working oh I've been working my new
[ __ ] in 25 30 minutes that I got since I
did the special not saying it's good not
saying it's it's deserves to be listened
to by human ears but they have to
because that's just how the game is
played so I went up the hell was I I was
at the I said I'm not even gonna say
that comedy clubs now because I don't
wanna get anybody in trouble but I was
on stage and you know the usual [ __ ]
that happens now when you do a [ __ ]
comedy show is everybody's having a
great time and then a younger white
woman all of a sudden has to [ __ ] be
offended by something right so I was
joking about that and you know then lo
and behold I'm doing my set and all of a
sudden this woman starts bitching about
something I go ah the classic there she
is the young white woman doesn't like
the joke the host showed us to stop and
she goes I'm not white
you know and the lights were in my eyes
it was like well you look white I can't
even see I go what are you she's like
I'm Asian you she said it with a real
attitude I go well Jesus Oh [ __ ]
relax stop acting like you've special
this like six billion are you sitting
here talking about yourself like you're
a [ __ ] albino alligator someone wants
to make a bag out of direct credit she
laughed her ass off now I know that was
taken out of context when on a comedy
club you're listening to this at home or
maybe at work and maybe they had
offended you and you need a hashtag
something that was [ __ ] funny she was
cool though thank God she ended up being
cool but I tried out all my new [ __ ] and
I actually was down in the village
afterwards and I've been working this
abortion angle and I got pro-choice
people I got him to give me an applause
break on something that was not
pro-choice on the [ __ ] issue which
made me feel great and just had a was
like the perfect night and then virzi
and Bobby Kelly were there and we went
oh my got to tell this [ __ ] story so
Mersey gets a like a box of [ __ ]
Cuban cigars as did I we both a buddy of
ours got a house [ __ ] he doesn't even
know this yet he's got to know now he
got us this box of Cuban cigars and he
sent us pictures going what do you want
you want all Cubans or do you want this
mix of Cuban cigars right so I'm like
well I'll take the mix you know I'll
take the whole smorgasbord there right
so / zi gross he didn't know the same
guy you know it's a buddy of ours he
paired us both up and sent us and we you
know he didn't have us on the same like
tax change so neither one of us knew he
goes dude I got up I got the variety box
I go did you get it from so-and-so he
goes yeah and it goes great so I'll meet
you down the cellar right he goes I had
Cubans and we're all excited right I go
down I do a couple two three sets I have
a great sets verse II [ __ ] murder
heard by the wavers he's gonna be at
laughs Boston this weekend please go out
and see this guy man
okay [ __ ] this guy's the real deal
and like he has turned a [ __ ] corner
and he is not the same comic when he
headlines that he is when he's open and
for me there's a whole other level that
he goes to just because he has the time
to really work ideas and I'm so thrilled
for him and watching you know there's
nothing I enjoy better than seeing a
comic you know all of a sudden they got
like that growth thing they turned the
corner and all that you know inspires
you to [ __ ] try and push yourself and
yada yada yada and all that right so
anyway so we're gonna alter that but
also reminds me when we were sitting in
the park Bobby Kelly's gone Jesus Christ
I had to go in after Jessica Kirsten and
I was like oh man that's a tough that's
a rough one he goes yeah he goes she can
like she goes dude she's like three
comics and one she can do voices and I
even I jumped on earth I go she can be
big she can just be standing there she's
got like every tool in the [ __ ]
toolbox and by the way oh what a
coincidence all things comedy produced
her upcoming special along with Ian
Edwards another beast so it was just a
great night so we're upstairs at the
cellar about ready to go over there and
Bobby's into cigars too and what you
have to understand about Bobby Kelly is
Bobby when Bobby gets into [ __ ] number
one Tom Cruise was talking about
Scientology and he was just like I
[ __ ] get into [ __ ] you know which is
the reference we used on f is for family
when when when Vic Reynolds go I get
into [ __ ] that was a run odd to him
flying helicopters whatever Tom Cruise
does you know this stunt to be done next
thing you know they're duck taking them
to the side of a [ __ ] 747 I mean
lunatic but in a good way cuz you got to
enjoy what the [ __ ] they do right and I
was gonna say so Bobby's the same way
right and he gets into [ __ ] he [ __ ]
gets into [ __ ] so he got into cigars
all right I'm into cigars but like I'm
not like one of these [ __ ] people
like you know I'm not like a connoisseur
you know I know about some cigars but
like any one of you out there could
educate me on this is a Connecticut leaf
and all of that I think those guys and
they light them and they're like oh no
I'm too agents of hints of chili pepper
with it with some chocolate of some
chocolate aftertaste and it [ __ ]
drives me up the wall because first of
all they know what the [ __ ] they're
gonna say before they light they lit it
they already took it and it's like
they're lighting it and they're already
hearing feeling hints of this and hints
of that like they're this [ __ ]
five-star chef the [ __ ] out of here all
right
yo League cigar I've ever lit whereas I
was lighting it I was like oh my god was
a any Cuban cigar I've ever smoked that
was actually real so anyway we're at the
cellar and first he's like I got Cubans
and Bobby's think he got Cubans yeah or
maybe I was excited so Bobby's just
sitting there right like the [ __ ]
dawn of cigars he's sitting it you know
like when that guy in Goodfellas comes
in he has a problem with this restaurant
he's just so only want me to I don't
know what the restaurant is right so big
virzi I mean Bobby just goes let me see
him so Ferrazzi gives him the box he
glances at the cigars and immediately he
puts it he puts on his glasses
he lifts Seeley's looking on the side of
the box he's not looking at the cigars
and I immediately knew what he was gonna
do I was like oh no he put on his
glasses that I swear to God looked like
the windshield on a [ __ ] motor
scooter east lens giant [ __ ] glasses
and that was not in a lit room was not
enough he then took the flashlight on
his phone and puts it on the serial
number and as he was doing in my head
I'm like don't do this Bobby please
don't ruin the night before it begins
and he looks at me just and he just puts
the Box down and shuts off the light
takes off his glasses and looks at first
he just goes these are fake
Rosie's going like now no they're not no
they're not you guys now that fake he
goes every Cuban cigar they come with
the serial number Bobby knew what the
serial number was and he's like these
are fake
okay so I'm [ __ ] dying laughing
Mersey Versys like Mersey is like he's
like Santa Claus you know this is what
you need to know about Paul big Paul
bercy's heart is he every year no matter
what the Knicks do he still has hope the
next season he is first virzi is
Christmas the whole [ __ ] year around
right sober Z shoulders literally like
slump I mean I go no no they're probably
good where did we go to get the same we
walking out and I just look at by got
buff why would you do that he's like
what do you do if a kid go that's the
Papa go that's not how you do it and he
starts laughing I go this is what you
should have done you should have
realized they were fake and then what
you do is just sit there smoke them tell
him that they're good and then in a
couple weeks show up you know to go
smoke with the guy say by the way you
know those Cuban cigars you had a few
weeks ago and he goes yeah by the way
those with in with those weren't real
they were fake and then you pull out and
go but here's here's a real one okay and
then you could educate him on the serial
number and all that so Bobby goes
alright fair enough fair enough right
and then birds he goes yeah do it I
don't think these are fake he starts it
back up again forever the hopeful Nick
fan he starts it back up again and at
that point I got I Paul not now I now I
got to turn my back on you Paul Sorvino
I got to turn my back I tried to [ __ ]
stick up for the moment and it's over so
then we ended up but we wouldn't up
going to that park right across the
street from Joe's pizza the one you see
at the end of Ray Romano is amazing
special if you haven't watched it yet so
at that point we were all just laughing
and I was like Bob which one do you want
do you want the pho Heba or the fart
agus you know basically using the Cuban
names but saying F for fake and we were
all just laughing but they actually
smoked good and
didn't taste that bad and then a buddy
of ours ended up showing up we had like
the [ __ ] best night sitting there
smoking the cigar looking at the
ridiculously long line over a Jos
waiting for it to get small enough that
we were going to go over there and get a
slice of pizza and I I wasn't going to
get a slice because I've been eating too
many and I got to keep my girlish figure
here for the for the motion-picture all
right I don't want my [ __ ] I don't
want my [ __ ] second trimester
alabaster belly taken away from the true
star of the show which is my mustache so
we just sat there the whole night then
we just started talking about how much
money do you think Jose is make it and
[ __ ] you know my dad always wanted to
open a pizza parlor Birds he want to
open a pizza parlor and all that [ __ ] we
just sat there shooting the [ __ ] and
just I came in like it was a grown-up
stay it's a classic great cigar where it
was just like great cigar hang I should
say before Bobby calls it dude it wasn't
great deal with fake did did that
conversation in the park had a serial
number on it that wasn't real that
wasn't real conversation we just said we
talked comedy that's what we're we were
talking about assets and Bobby was
talking about having to follow Jessica
and I don't just had like the greatest
the greatest [ __ ] night and I don't
know it's why you know as much as a good
time as I had drinking booze for all
those years I can kind of walk away from
that because you know there's an
inebriation obviously involved with
boozing even if you just have a couple
and a lot of great conversation is lost
but was to go at but even then I got I
got to go easy on the cigars okay this
whole talk is making me want to smoke
one right now but I will tell you last
night I went out and I did big J's skank
fest
I never you know so it's funny is I
never really put that today I know what
that word means but I never because of
fest at the end of it like you can call
something [ __ ] fest and when I showed up
and there was an orgy there I would
still be surprised like once once fest
is at the end of it that the prefix is
no longer as a single word anymore it's
just the beginning of it and a doesn't
doesn't even dawn on me and I'm not
saying that there was a bunch of skanks
there but it was just like it reminded
me the energy was like when you used to
do those Opie and Anthony live events
where it was crazy
maniacal fans with ridiculously awesome
loyalty and it was slightly scary so we
went up there we played we did the
goddamn comedy Jim and I got to take by
the time I went up there Josh Adam
Meyers it looked like somebody had
thrown him in an above-ground pool with
his clothes on he was absolutely
drenched in sweat I've never seen all
these people hardest-working man in show
business I never saw anybody sweating
like that he was absolutely soaked his
shorts his shirt his hair the whole
[ __ ] thing he looked like a [ __ ]
like I said he looked like someone just
threw him in a [ __ ] pool and we went
up there and I haven't had a lot of time
to play on a kit because did I mention
I'm doing a movie 550 times in this
[ __ ] thing alright though we get it
for once you're working as an actor but
I did I went out and I bought a practice
pad and I've been working on my hands
there trying to remember some [ __ ] that
Davey leach Elitch taught me and just
doing that I think I played the best
I've played I mean still saying I'm not
saying it was good but I wasn't nervous
or anything so of course I you play you
do better if you weren't nervous but I
got to play kickstart my heart with old
the teen idol sensation from the Opie
and Anthony program Joe DeRosa came back
out and saying kickstart my heart it
dawn on me till afterwards when I left
that was like wait a minute I finally
got to jam with [ __ ] Joe DeRosa and
dude the crowd was [ __ ] insane they
were [ __ ] it's I don't know if you've
seen some of the clips from it but like
Bobby Kelly crowd-surf Dale honey at is
but a podcast Bobby these Cubans aren't
real Kelly anyway and then we played a
Pantera I'm broken
aka downtown comedy club downtown comedy
club which we don't even call it I'm
broken anymore now Josh Cruz you want to
do downtown yeah we'll do downtown and
then Joey roses is going to sing
kickstart my heart and it was like it
was [ __ ] awesome I could barely hear
the guitar in the bass but I was just
sort of humming the song along so I you
know there was a couple of minor train
wrecks in there that were my fault but I
think overall when I was on it I
actually played it pretty good so I was
very excited about that so then I go to
run out of it because there was no place
to hang out I mean it was like it was a
[ __ ] free-for-all in the greatest
sense I think everybody there he just
walked in and had a backstage pass I
wanted the greenroom there was like 400
[ __ ] people in there it felt like but
honestly was probably like I know
upwards of 30 people in a room that
comfortably would have held seven so
that was the only part trying to figure
out a place where I could stand and kind
of think about you know the song so I
didn't blow it and you know I got to see
some of red bands stand-up show
downstairs who the [ __ ] did I see Josh
went up and did a set
Tony the show pony I got to see him
he had a great bit about transgendered
athletes and yeah I think that that was
it so anyway afterwards and this [ __ ]
venue by the way Jesus Christ I mean
you could have shot a horror movie in
this place it was out of the 70s and
literally nothing had been changed I
mean we were in the sober greenroom we
finally found one downstairs and what
was hilarious we walked in there was one
person there so we went in there and
they had these these round rounded like
leather sort of cheap-ass looking
minimalist chairs unlike these literally
look like they're from the set of like
Mary Tyler Moore's apartment but anyway
we had we ended up having a great time
so I do this I do the show right play
kick start in downtown comedy club right
and they had a great [ __ ] time I get
off stage and I'm gonna overwrite and I
go outside and there's this lime-green
taxi sitting there as if I had already
called it I'm like what a [ __ ]
perfect night you know I get to do big
J's [ __ ] festival i I [ __ ] jam
with Joe DeRosa I don't [ __ ] up the
songs too bad everything goes great and
here's a cab waiting for me I said hey
you want and he's like yes right and I
go to get in and I II goes where you
going and I was like I'm going to 81st
and 3rd he's like 81st and third I go
yeah in Manhattan he's like Manhattan
yeah Manhattan eight one and three I go
yes Manhattan I'm like yeah New York
City Empire State Building if I can make
it there right and then I'm thinking
like oh my god we're in Brooklyn he
doesn't want to go all the way out there
he's a lime green cab he's gonna have to
drive back empty so I just I [ __ ] say
to the guy do you not want to go and he
goes no no how do you want to go Midtown
Tunnel you want to take the Williamsburg
Bridge and I'm like whatever you think
is faster you want to go Midtown
Williamsburg yeah yeah I got whichever
81 and three and I just go to go [ __ ]
yourself and I got a [ __ ]
Jim I knew what he was doing but I had
to commend it the fact that in a second
language he still knew how to play dumb
so he could get what the [ __ ] he wanted
it was such passive-aggressive horseshit
but I got I have to commend him that it
did work and then he had the audacity as
I'm standing there across the street
waiting for my uber he was he was
outside of his car leaning on his car
just looking at me likes like the guy
that Clint Eastwood kills in a Western
you know I mean like you know I mean you
can just tell like this guy's just gonna
be a dick I mean maybe he was mad at me
but I didn't overreact
cuz I went to get out of his cab and I
was waitin no way at the butt and he
didn't do it he just let me get out
[ __ ] [ __ ]
by the way my temper is back in full
force because I have not [ __ ] gone to
therapy and been able to talk about my
and the big thing about it's been
helping me about the therapy is I'm
always thinking in my head like well if
I talk about this then I have to go in
and talk to her and say that I failed
this week now I don't have that I don't
have the parameters so I got I got a I
got to get it back under control I mean
it does make for great stories here in
the podcast I imagine it's [ __ ] I said
like 9 times a day 1 and 3 it's just
like dude your entire country is better
at math than some of our best students
over here okay we've got a couple of
ageing Asian free agents but generally
white people you crush us in math you
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about so
anyway I got a couple of days off here
and I got to go to a barber and get this
[ __ ] mustache trimmed because it is
like gonna be hanging down below my
bottom lip here and I'm like I can't do
what everything gets in it I don't know
how the [ __ ] the clever love commitment
to having one of these [ __ ] hipster
[ __ ] Sam Elliott mustaches is it's
starting to get it's starting to wear on
me all right
Oh Billy Dallas buyers club here is has
had it so I got you know I think I wrap
the second week in August and I'm gonna
clear it with the director and be like
all right dude I'm gonna go home and
shave this off are we cool
because it's gonna take me you know six
to seven weeks to grow this [ __ ] again
yeah I'm gonna go back to being Billy
red-faced I miss that guy did anybody
watch the f1 race I actually caught it
caught it and I watched it in Spanish
and even in Spanish I knew the [ __ ]
race was over the second Lewis Hamilton
may you know right as they say it's a
race to the first turn and I'll tell you
I couldn't believe that that Lewis
Hamilton had won the pole and valtteri
botas was in second place it's
unbelievable I mean I thought the other
ninety weeks in a row that they've
seemed to have done that was just a
fluke the a level of driver of Lewis
Hamilton in the level of car that he's
in and he's in the pole position and he
gets the first turn I can tell you this
like there's no point in watching the
rest of the [ __ ] race it's you how
they even like televised the race
they're not even showing Lewis Hamilton
they're not even showing the guy in
first place they spend the whole race
showing like [ __ ] third fourth and
fifth those people jockeying for
position that's where the racing is but
it's still an incredible sport but I
gotta tell you like they need to there's
gonna have to be some something they
have to do something all right there's
got to be that something's got to give
here we're like you know in hockey they
got rid of the red line so you could
have the stretch pass to somehow beat
that [ __ ] you know trap defense which
now is going to be can you beat a trap
defense while they're running your
goaltender and [ __ ] cross-checking
you in the teeth like those piece of
[ __ ] st. Louis Blues it's gradually
going to come out because I wanted to be
classy when they want filthy filthy
[ __ ] team but you know Bruins have
had filthy teams that's how I'm making
my peace with it
but it just kills me we should have run
their [ __ ] mediocre goddamn
goaltender which by the way now that
you've had your parade because I don't
want to rain on your parade now that
it's gone dude
that [ __ ] horseshit where they was
but more games than any other [ __ ]
rookie did that that [ __ ] guy if we
scored the first [ __ ] goal the guy
let up ten goals in two games it was
pulled out of one game everybody [ __ ]
relax all right you got a Matt Cassell
situation he gets traded to the hockey
equivalent of the Chiefs ten years ago
and that guy's a [ __ ] sieve but
haven't said that congratulations on
your Cup the [ __ ] was his goals against
ten goals in two [ __ ] games jesus
[ __ ] christ and they just sitting
there ball washing the guy these are
reason why was he I thought it was the
[ __ ] Goins he had in front of him
[ __ ] takin runs at people and boarding
everybody I thought it was that call me
crazy
anyways where am I let's read some
advertising here alright
oh I mean good news and better news here
I was actually home I was visiting as I
sort of alluded to one of my friends is
uh gravely ill and you know that's never
fun but I did go back and I met up with
a bunch of my high school buddies who
I've still been in touch with thirty
some odd years and we we hung out and we
were all talking about the hangover of
when the NHL and the NBA playoffs end
because there's such high let's watch a
baseball game is born ago now I put it
on settle and settle in it's [ __ ]
great it's a great [ __ ] game right and
we happened to watch that Red Sox game
where we were down forward enough
against the Blue Jays and we came back
and won seven to five and ten innings
ended up being a great game and we were
talking about the old days and all of
that [ __ ] and I read the next day in the
Boston sports page which I never get to
read anymore I think I have a
subscription to both the globe and The
Herald I just don't remember my
passwords
they were talking about our coach was it
Cora I'm so not a baseball guy right now
our managers decision I guess we brought
a pitcher in and we walked somebody to
get to a guy who was four four four for
the night and everyone was scratching
their heads but the pitcher we had was
the guy had gone off for three lifetime
against him so everybody thought that he
walked him because the four four four
guy he had never got a hit on our
pitcher and he said our manager was like
that's not why I did it I did it because
he was four for four and it's almost you
know it's really difficult to go five
for five so he was betting on the fact
that all right this guy got four hits
but there's no way he's getting five I
never heard anybody do the math like
that in baseball and somehow it worked
out so I know we're not playing the
greatest baseball and the Yankees are
absolutely on wire on fire and now
they're and they weren't even playing
with their best guys so I'm definitely
going to be keeping an eye on that
because as I keep mentioning the Yankees
win it this year who they got it was
good a chance as anybody
like I said they will keep that they
they will have won at least one World
Series in nine of the last ten decades
no yeah unbelievable
that's un-fuckin'-believable to be that
successful for that long and even as a
Red Sox fan I have to give it up to you
and congratulations to the Blues there's
just a few things I was just biting my
tongue watching that [ __ ] [ __ ]
because I didn't want to be the [ __ ]
sore loser but here I am two weeks later
still [ __ ] steaming over did you see
what the Bruins drafted to drafted a
[ __ ] six foot three 200 something
pound [ __ ] Center I told you that's
what we needed we didn't have that power
forward to stand there in the slot
that's what we needed so we were pass
and wing to [ __ ] wing and that
amazing Patrick walk Junior he went from
one post to the other alright honey
today's show is brought to you by honey
the easiest way to save money when
you're shopping online honestly before I
found out about honey honey see the from
honestly before I found out about honey
seeing the promo code box at checkout
stressed me out yeah anything on
computer stresses me up
honey we'll have you find lab we'll find
you every coupon code sale or discount
on over 20,000 sites like Amazon j.crew
eBay Macy's Sephora Nordstrom and more
do you realize this is literally built
for guys like me
who are afraid of computers and can't
figure out where I mean I can't even use
the [ __ ] stove the oven I figured out
this stove but the oven I couldn't even
figure out I couldn't figure out how to
raise the temperature so then I had to
do the math me all right 25 minutes at
400 I can only get it to be the standard
350 here what is that like 32 minutes
let me just it's on off and I had the
[ __ ] numbers it wasn't any easier
than that why does it have to have a
digital [ __ ] code you know why that
is it's because they just want to keep
getting you to keep buying the next
[ __ ] thing to remind me to talk about
cardio machines after this read here
honey we'll find you every coupon sale a
discount on over on over 20,000 sites
like Amazon j.crew eBay Macy's Sephora
Nordstrom and more we've got your back
so you might ask how do I know honey has
my back does it really work well not
only did honey's test over 1 billion
promo codes last year but it actually
applied 185 million 67,000 no sorry
yeah 185 million 67,000 86 working codes
to people's orders that's a lot of real
life savings just it is not to mention
over 10 million people are already
saving with honey and it has over
100,000 five-star reviews the google
chrome store on the google chrome store
thanks to honey
now there's literally no stress when I
see that promo code at checkout please
interject personal experience of how
honey has saved you I haven't used it
yet I want to use it I got to get it
where do I get it
look there's no reason not to use honey
it's free it's [ __ ] free which means
the advertisers are given them money
these people are you gonna buy from
they take the [ __ ] hit right is that
how it works - just bring all of us
there it's free to use and easy to
install any computer just two clicks
never overthink the promo code again get
honey for free at join honeycomb / /
that's join honeycomb / / honey online
savings simplified what do we got here
ah look who's here it's hymns hymns
you've heard us talking about him and
how they are helping guys look their
best if you haven't yet it's time to see
what they're all about 66% of men start
losing their hair by age 35 once you've
noticed thinning hair it can be too late
is that hairline slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yet the best
way to prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
some it's time to get a handle on those
precious locks do you want to do you
want a bald spot to pop up on your
hairline - wait do you want a bald spot
to pop up or your hairline to recede or
do you want to do something about it
first from my personal experience it's
better to have a receding hairline than
to be losing in the back you lose it in
the back you're gonna meet in the middle
in the middle of your head that's the
way it's gonna go for hims calm if you
lose it in the front you can kind of
just keep combing it forward for a while
and look like you're in a [ __ ] cover
band for the Beatles but do you really
want to do that why don't you just go to
four hymns calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
no more awkward in-person doctor visits
or long pharmacy lines for him connects
you to real doctors online which could
save you hours completely confidential
and discreet answers a few quick
questions a doctor will review and if
they determine it's right for you you
can can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your door get the hair loss treatment
everyone is talking about featured in GQ
Men's Health Esquire and Playboy to name
a few my listeners can get started with
the hems complete hair kit for just 5
bucks right now while supplies last and
subject to doctor's approval I don't
know what that means
see website for full details and safety
information this could cost hundreds if
you went to the doctor or our pharmacy
or somewhere else go to for hims dot-com
slash bird that's fo r hims com / /
that's for hims comm slash bur you know
what I'm actually fascinated with rock
bands all-male rock bands where nobody
loses their hair you know I mean that
can't be real somebody must have done it
for hims you know you look at Aerosmith
they all got their hair you look at the
Rolling Stones they all got their hair
Keith was starting to lose it you know
we started wearing the bandanas and then
we got Johnny Depp doing the [ __ ]
Pirates of the Caribbean because of that
going this guy's dressing like a pirate
I think he was doing the LeBron James he
was wearing the [ __ ] headband and
then I don't know I just saw him
recently and he got it back he looked
like he had a [ __ ] decaying bird's
nest on his head for a long time and
being the fact that he was a smoker I
was really concerned for you know when
he was [ __ ] lighting it up you know if
they well for someone of the Amber's
there you know like how like those those
LA fires the Amber's will float over
other houses and just [ __ ]
unfortunate land on somebody else's
house and someone's sitting there across
the street looking at three houses that
burnt down in their whole block they're
all [ __ ] a side of the block is fine
it's like a tornado we got it built all
right butchers bucks this month what
your box is offering free bacon for life
sign up now and you'll get one package
of the best tasting bacon free and every
box for you can imagine me in the
Rolling Stones and you don't lose your
hair and you got great [ __ ] hair it's
just like you know you got to be
thinking what did I do in a past life
this much puts butchers boxes offering
free bacon for life sign up now and you
get one package of the best tasting
baking free free in every box for life
for the life of your subscription
butcher box bacon is whole 30 approved
uncured nitrate and sugar free right now
new members will get a package
bacon for free in every box for the life
year's subscription plush you get $20
off your first box oh this is that all
of this stuff is my favorite out of
everybody who's advertised every month
butcher box delivers 100% grass-fed and
grass-finished beef free-range or garden
organic chicken and my favorite heritage
breed pork the best pork chop I've ever
made and while the last can Sam and
directly to your door the incredible
quality of butcher box meat starts with
the commitment to humanely raised
animals that are never fed antibiotics
or hormones before they get whacked like
Joe Pesci and [ __ ] Goodfellas did we
mention it's delivered right to your
door choose from four curated boxes
including a mix of high-quality
grass-fed grass-finished beef free-range
organic chicken and heritage breed pork
or customize your own box so you can get
exactly what you and your family love
butcher box also has wild con Alaskan
salmon sockeye salmon what did you call
me I just said it Alaskan salmon I
thought you called me a sockeye salmon
and butcher box
bacon that is sourced from heritage
breed pigs and is uncured nitrate free
and sugar free by the way if you didn't
know what heritage breed pork pigs are
they can trace their bloodline back to
Europe
these are purebred pigs the best of the
best when it comes to pork alright they
aren't the bastardized version over here
like me where I'm you know German Irish
Scottish Dutch French right I think I
got a little English in there I know
what the [ __ ] it is now these are 100%
European [ __ ] pigs I don't know what
they do to the European pigs over there
I don't know if it's the [ __ ] DJ
music you know the house music they
listen to I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is the EDM but they just taste better
than the ones over here that are
listening to our [ __ ] you know my
favorite cut is on the pork chop without
a doubt average bread pork there's no
easier way to get high-quality meat you
can trust there's no commitment and you
can cancel at any time to receive $20
off your first box box and a package of
free bacon in every box for the life of
your subscription go to butcher box com
/ / enter
at checkout goal now it's a limited time
offer good lord everybody is there
anything more American than a package of
free bacon in every box eat whatever
subscription you have all right let's
talk cardio machines because that's what
I've been doing and this friend of mine
was claiming there was a new cardio
machine where he's burning way more
calories than you do on an elliptical at
the same amount of time and it just
dawned on me I was just like that's just
sort of like the scam with cardio
equipment is that once people buy
something they're so [ __ ] expensive
it's like they're not gonna you know my
mother bought a [ __ ] NordicTrack in
the late 80s she's still using it still
works up a sweat and all of that [ __ ]
right she got it for my dad he never
[ __ ] used it and she uses it right so
the thing about that game is is in order
to get people to buy again you have to
you have to somehow come up with some
sort of device that is it's burning more
calories in a shorter amount of time all
right
and the thing about that is it just it
just says enter your age enter your
weight and what else there's something
else I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
and then it just says well you burn this
many calories it's like don't you need
more information than that I don't have
a [ __ ] science background obviously
I'm not a personal trainer
obviously Hey right but I said like what
do you what the [ __ ] you doing I think
they just fudged the [ __ ] numbers to
drive the market so I just looked up I
just looked up cardio machines scam and
I found this [ __ ] article first of
all first of all was funny was most of
them were trying to sell you cardio
equipment and this article that I ended
up reading this guy was breaking down
all the ways why those things are
they're not accurate because it's
basically like if some if I was to get
on a cardio machine in the shape that
I'm in and work out at a certain level
like it's it's gonna be challenging to
my body type right if someone else of
like the exact same whatever proportions
as me who on paper we are the same but
they they have more like athletic DNA or
whatever and they barely break a sweat
they're gonna say that they [ __ ] burn
the same thing like everybody's like
different you would need you need so
much more [ __ ] information and I
really just feel like the whole [ __ ]
thing is a scam I'm not saying cardio
machines are bad I'm just saying
buy one and if it still [ __ ] works
don't get suckered into buying something
else this guy wrote a whole article just
on elliptical machine saying it's the
most useless thing and that's the one
that I use and he was saying that
they're absolutely [ __ ] useless cuz
at least a Stairmaster is something you
can apply in real life walking up stairs
or going up a [ __ ] Hill a rowing
machine you know for when you take your
lilia [ __ ] the love of your life around
a lake I don't know who the [ __ ] rose
anymore if you're escaping Alcatraz you
know and you made a [ __ ] dinghy out
of a [ __ ] pair of pants and some
shirts that you tied together what else
but like yeah an elliptical like unless
I got oh I don't want you get
cross-country ski I have no [ __ ] idea
I don't know what the point of any of
that was oh the point was the body was
going you got to get on this thing it
burns way more calories and I'm just you
know being a pessimistic son of a [ __ ]
isn't the greatest thing in life but
like it does prevent you from going out
and falling for [ __ ] like that it's like
how do they know how the [ __ ] do they
know what the [ __ ] you're burning you
just tell them your age and your weight
they don't know how much of that is fat
how much of that is muscle you don't
have to say how tall you are and most of
them right do you have a little fat [ __ ]
and then a tall skinny guy and they're
trying to say that they burn the same
calories you know the fatties almost
dying and it all stretch over there he's
barely breaking a sweat
dad I'll tell you all right let's uh
let's do some of the reads here for the
week how much time have I done here only
I don't like about this new [ __ ] one
it's difficult to figure that all right
41 minutes in okay Whoopi and Bella
Thorne from a lady all right so last
week I was talking about Whoopi's
response to this this celebrity who
would send some naked photos to her
boyfriend and they were on the cloud and
some [ __ ] got him and then he tried
to blackmail her and then Whoopi was
just like what the [ __ ] you doing that
for you famous and I was like that's
exactly what my mother would have said
hey Billy bald [ __ ] this is from a lady
I love when the lady's right in the
thing about what Whoopi said is that I
think thorne realizes she made a mistake
we'll be just jumping in like hey
dumbass that was dumb I'm older and
smile I'm older yeah look at that look
at that you throw in a little shade her
way and smarter than you you shouldn't
have been so dumb isn't helpful that's
not what she said that's not what she
said all right she goes if I went
swimming and lost a foot to a shark you
know that's a great comparison I think
that you know uploading naked photos of
yourself that somebody black man you
look [ __ ] great by the way I didn't
see him but like I saw Joy Behar was
going like I've had a body like that I'd
[ __ ] blast him around the subway
I love joy by the way I got to work with
her and crashing she's [ __ ] hilarious
she goes if I went swimming and lost a
foot to a shark and the paramedic just
comes up and says hey [ __ ]
you should have known sharks are in the
ocean I'm not going to check if you're
all right
just need you to know you were an idiot
I [ __ ] realize I made a mistake you
don't need to publicly chastise me all
right that that that right there first
of all what you're saying Whoopi said
she didn't say and then this this
comparison is not the same thing okay a
paramedics job is to come up to you if
you're bleeding is to stop the bleeding
to get you to the doctors at the
hospital while you're still alive that's
his job
Whoopi
job is not to make this person feel
better okay and she didn't say hey
dumbass that was dumb I'm older and
smarter than you you shouldn't be so
dumb that's not what she said okay and
the thing about you [ __ ] people about
people in general is you know when you
[ __ ] up in life if somebody doesn't hold
your feet to the fire speaking of feet
you're not gonna learn anything if
people are just constantly coddling you
all right you don't learn anything and
then secondly this is a famous person
famous people are not people they are
just things that people use to get
through ten minutes of their [ __ ] day
on a radio show or a [ __ ] blog that
they don't feel like doing that day so
part of being in the public eye is
getting trashed all right at the [ __ ]
pathetic level then I'm at all right I
sigh literally I stopped reading
comments on social media years ago
because it's literally like like 80%
negative that's basically what happens
all right but what I liked about what
Whoopi said was it was old-school
parenting all right yeah you [ __ ] up
just cuz you're [ __ ] up doesn't mean
you deserve a hug and somebody cries on
your shoulder I'm not saying that you
don't deserve that okay but somebody
also needs to like you know if you're
just like oh my god this happened and
I'm a victim and somebody just goes yeah
that's so terrible oh my god I hope
you're okay
like what did you learn if you take a
jump shot at the end of the game when
there was a guy underneath and you
missed the [ __ ] shot and everybody
boos you and then you're in the locker
room crying is the coach not supposed to
bring up that there was a guy open
underneath
that had a way higher percentage of a
shot next time you get into that [ __ ]
situation you know I will say this what
she didn't do in the end was what a
great coach would do is after he gave
his [ __ ] for [ __ ] up he would then
built don't worry you'll get him next
time but Bob would love a BA all right I
will give you that she didn't do that
but it was refreshing to have somebody
like hold somebody [ __ ] responsible
for their [ __ ] actions I mean it was
a little ridiculous that you're just
gonna [ __ ] that you're gonna do
something like that I don't know she is
younger I don't [ __ ] I don't I don't
know but I mean I don't know listen I
may be saying Whoopi was right all I
knew was it made me miss my mom well
what'd you do that for you idiot she
always used to do that
yeah well that's what you get for
climbing a tree I mean you got to hang
on all right Saturday dear Billy
linguine mystics greetings from Rome ah
what am I gonna grate trips I ever took
you're constantly emphasizing the Oh a
today and Saturday with a Boston accent
is that from something or is it just how
Boston drunks talk when their Boston
level drunk love your music choices well
that's Andrew That's not me
Andrew makes the music choices oh hey
hey I'm gonna come over there on say
it's an exact it's an exaggeration of
Saturday and there's some people say
Saturday
that's what it is why don't you come
over on Saturday we'll figure it out you
know it's like really a hardier Boston
accent so me and my buddies being living
in LA and missing the Boston accent
exaggerated to the point that became say
hey but it's much go this Saturday
my mother-in-law came over this past
Saturday and she was in rare form
that's where it comes from it just comes
from well it really comes from yeah
being there and then also watching Steve
Sweeney making fun of the Boston accent
and when all of us comics from the
Boston sea scene all ended up in LA at
the same time that was you know it was
you know it was a [ __ ] culture shock
to go from Boston all the way out to LA
it's just so [ __ ] different both
great cities and I love both of them but
we were young and we just you know we
didn't know anything our whole lives
were spent in Massachusetts New
Hampshire Maine all of these guys that I
moved out there with roughly the same
time so the way we dealt with Holmes
being homesick is we hung out with each
other and as we were starting to lose
our Boston accents like as much as I
still have one that's it's not it's not
even remotely what it used to be I have
a very soft Boston accent if you can
believe that
so someone be like going yeah we just
say something like that would be like
yeah dude I gotta wash my car today and
blah blah blah washer what and they'd be
like car what and he go yeah that's what
we just said we'd always like when we
heard somebody pronounce an R we were
just I don't know why we would do that
it was [ __ ] stupid but uh I remember
one of the hardest laughs I ever had
when I was out there in LA we were doing
time in this now-defunct the LA cabaret
and I came in what the [ __ ] it was
called it was just way out in the valley
this [ __ ] comedy club it was in this
strip mall I forget what it was called
but we were out there and Bob Marley was
on stage and he was talking about moving
across the country with his wife and he
was telling the story and like there was
like eight people there and like seven
of them were comedians it was ridiculous
it was like nobody there and he was
standing there and he was going yeah
when we moved across country and he goes
we took a [ __ ] and he jumped up in
the air
shut up the air and landed in this squat
position he goes we took a [ __ ] rider
you know the Ryder truck and it was just
so silly and ridiculous and we were all
so frustrated that we weren't getting
good stage time a lot of us thinking
what the [ __ ] had we done that we just
fell out laughing and I funny like he
did that well over 20 years ago and I
never forgot it and to this day when I
Drive down the street and I see they're
not yellow anymore because the [ __ ]
idiots in the world trade I believe they
switch them to white whenever I see one
I always think of that every time it's
just a joke that keeps giving all right
dealing with parents hey Bill loved the
podcasts in your stand-up sorry he had a
bad experience at the airport last time
you were here in India hope you come
again sometime
no I didn't I didn't have like a bad I
had a terrifying experiences I don't
think they're gonna let me out anyways
they put the s there I'm 18 and recently
got accepted in a well respected
Engineering College
you see exactly a b18 one you know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
in India but I don't want to follow that
career I want to be a mechanic that's
cool man being a mechanic is [ __ ] cool
I contacted and scored an internship at
a huge Kustoms garage in Mumbai dude
that's a [ __ ] no-brainer the problem
is my parents told Jesus they are
forcing me to go to engineering schools
as it is safer choice according to them
they want me to take up computer science
my father brings one of his successful
friends home every day and together they
try to convince me my parents are not
bad people and I believe they did a
decent job raising me and I've always
supported me but this time they just
won't listen how do you think I should
talk to them and explain my passion
about cars and machines also would like
to know your thoughts on Macs first app
and thanks dude you got to follow your
heart and sometimes your parents you
know what I've learned is
being a parent the short amount of time
that I have is that there's an
unbelievable amount of fear these fear
if this is possible almost it is bigger
than the love you it's like recup is
because you love them so much that you
this fear that something bad is going to
happen to them so what they're worried
about is they they know that you know
you're gonna outlive them right so
they're worried they just want to know
that you're gonna be okay after they're
gone so that's where they're coming from
if that helps you understand it more and
maybe you can come with us and I know
that you guys are worried about my
future and you know I you know I I get
that or whatever and just like you want
me to be happy right this is what's
gonna make me happy I absolutely love
this I have a passion for this I would
do this for free
and I know I'm gonna be good enough with
the great you know jeans that I have
from you guys that I got accepted to
engineering school that like I can apply
this not the brains that you gave me to
this thing and I'll be one of the best
guys out there just talk yourself up but
I think you might have to go through a
couple years of their disappointment
until they see the success and I think
that's just something someday
that you guys will laugh about and if
they never do find it funny and they
never quite get that that's what you
liked and then they're just gonna have
to [ __ ] you know it's just one of
those things that you know your parents
aren't going to like everything that
you're doing but if you like it as long
as you're not this you know no more talk
about doing heroin it's just something
that they're gonna have to [ __ ] accept
that's all also would like to know so
definitely follow your heart all right
follow your heart man cuz I think I
think building custom cars and
everything is just [ __ ] amazing also
what do you want to know your thoughts
on max first app and thanks I love the
guy I think you know if he wasn't
driving for Red Bull it means there's a
lot of guys if they had
you know where the [ __ ] did botas come
from I mean he was good and everything
all the sudden get some Mercedes and
he's like the second best guy out there
it's just like Mercedes throws so much
money at the cars I mean what do you
think max Verstappen would be doing if
he was riding in a [ __ ] Mercedes I
think he would have way more podiums and
way more wins I think he's an incredible
driver and he I think he's he's gonna be
if he can get if he can get with a team
that has the [ __ ] money now like Red
Bull is totally poor but I feel like
they're a distant third but behind
Mercedes and Ferrari even though they're
doing better than Ferrari this year as
far as I know I've been kind of busy but
I think if he was driving a car
equivalent of that same thing as Daniel
Ricciardo I think there's a lot of guys
out there that could be which is a shame
and then you could really see some
incredible racing and I got to be honest
with you I don't know if they need to
make the tracks [ __ ] wider or what
but they got to do something where these
guys actually have an opportunity to
pass each other because you know I
watched 17 to 19 laps of that 50-some
lap race and I just kept looking at the
distance between botas and in Lewis
Hamilton he just kept getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and it got up to close
to six seconds it's like I'm not [ __ ]
watching this I got my kid I'm gonna go
take my kid to the park forget it I
thought I was gonna see a race here it's
now you know it's just you can't compete
with it but I think obviously if max
Verstappen was was Ryan for like driving
for like a Mercedes or something like
that I mean I can't imagine what he's
been doing I love him I think he's great
he also he has balls - he seems mature
beyond his years he's not intimidated by
the press he's got a little that Kimi
räikkönen in him you know I like him I
think I'm a huge fan of his alright
feminist question hey Billy badass love
the show I enjoy hearing you and the
lovely Nia on the podcast your
relationship dynamic is similar to mine
we were also an interracial couple
myself being a black woman me and my me
and boyfriend have been together for
about five years and have different
approaches to life my passion and career
are one in the same I'm conscious
trying to move up and make more my
boyfriend just works for money he
indulges his passions in his free time
i'ii make him use it he doesn't really
pay attention to how much he makes now
that we're talking about getting married
friends and family don't like the fact
that I am more ahead in my career and
feel he should pull his weight more
exactly exactly you see that you see
that all the feminists out there
listening to this [ __ ] I'm telling you
there's that [ __ ] thing out there you
know it's like if a guy isn't bringing
home the bacon he's like he's just an
adult teenager what are we doing here
you can't make a baby you have an
ingredient but you know got the Easy
Bake Oven there so what are you doing
you got to make money my only problem
with and she says money profit that is
the situation was reversed and he was
making more than me no one would care
because he's a man exactly sometimes I
wish he made closer to what I may make
but it isn't a priority for me in a
relationship what are your thoughts on
this love the show and go [ __ ] yourself
well I don't think there is a problem
with it inherently what the problem is
is when you get pregnant and you have to
go on leave what kind of sort of
financial situation that puts you in
because for some reason I'm assuming you
live in the United States is we don't
give a [ __ ] if a woman's pregnant we're
like all right well you just dropped off
keep the caravan moving you know there's
some countries they get upwards of six
weeks off they also play like ninety
percent taxes that's the part that they
don't tell talk to you about I I agree
with everything you're saying like if it
was flipped they wouldn't say anything
about you you know sometimes listen if
you love the guy [ __ ] marry the guy
you know if he's going to be a good dad
and all of that [ __ ] and you know if
this is the dynamic then make sure he
doesn't blow all the money he's making
on music don't squirrel away your money
save your [ __ ] money so that when you
having kids
you know it won't be a problem and then
have a number of kids that is conducive
to the money that you're making and I
think you can work it out you know and
don't forget to be nice to each other
all right I know that sounds easy but
you know you can just sort of just [ __ ]
and start taking somebody for granted
you'd be surprised how much a little
back rub goes either way you know
telling you all right the girl guys want
to [ __ ] but never want to date because
of big boobs okay what the [ __ ] is this
one going all right hey Bill and Nia I
just turned 29 years old on the 19th and
although I should be feeling great I've
been a little bit down about myself as
of recently I ended a five-year
relationship three years ago where I was
a lot heavier I thought my boobs were
just bigger because of my weight
I've lost 50 pounds since then and I
look and feel great
however the boobs never left me I've
been on dates with some guys but nothing
has really come of it a lot of them just
wanted to hook up and that's not really
my style for the first few dates I try
to address his modesty as I can I grew
up in a strict Catholic household so I
try not to show as much cleave as
possible it's really hard dressing
comfortably without looking like a
church choir singer and dying of
heatstroke parentheses I live in Arizona
my girlfriends and I met up for lunch a
few days ago I'm the only single friend
without kids in the group you know what
I bet a lot of them envy you on a lot of
days so before you get too down on
yourself there's this one lady in the
group who no one ever really likes
inviting because she's negative and
self-proclaimed Blount aka says rude ass
things just to say them they don't even
make sense oh yeah you got a sale Eid
Gay blunt I would have used a different
word that rhymes with blunt anyway the
subject came up of me seeing someone I
mentioned how it's nothing serious the
girl then goes on this rant about how my
boobs make me look like our girls guys
just one
- wanna [ __ ] but never want a date she
said that she's pointed out that they
make me look easy and a funtime girl she
said girls with smaller boobs get taken
more seriously because guys get to know
her her personally with boobs in her
face they cannot yeah she's jealous of
you also they don't want to worry about
their friends staring I brushed it off
at first just thinking she was being a
[ __ ] but the more I think of it the
more it bugged me and kind of made sense
is this true no no it's not even
remotely true that's a [ __ ] she's a [ __ ]
alright and your friends just sat back
and just let her say that I gotta be
honest with you this sounds like you're
one of those real housewife dynamics
that I watched my wife watch and why I'm
just like why did [ __ ] would anybody
hang out with a person like that so we
just said something like that to you
don't you don't work that out the fact
that she said that and was that [ __ ]
rude in public and not thinking about
your feelings whatsoever
instead in front of all your friends
dude [ __ ] her and in a lot of ways [ __ ]
you